boris johnson calls a fix to the social
care system uh and it really comes in
two halves there's a series of tax rises
and all sorts of different people far
more groups of people i think than we
were expecting even uh three or four
days ago and then we've got the outline
of a system uh to solve initially for
the first uh three or so years um the
backlog of the nhs and then that money
transfers uh into a new uh rewired
social care system uh helping people
avoid selling their houses in order to
pay for
care if they get
dementia or other long-term debilitating
conditions need to go into the nursing
home and also some money that's going
into the social care system uh itself uh
now so an absolutely huge uh
set of changes let's look first of all
at the tax system so as you mentioned a
1.25 increase in national insurance um
for employers the same 1.25
increase in national
insurance for employees now once upon a
time george osborne used to call that a
jobs tax when it was banded about as a
possible levy that labour might impose
but now the conservatives have embraced
that
but on top of that a couple of uh
interesting and unexpected tweaks uh
from
2024 that levy which will appear on your
pay slips as a health and social care
levy will also be uh made to be paid by
pensioners who are working so that is a
big change because at the moment
national insurance uh isn't something
that uh pensioners have to pay uh but
from uh 2024 uh 2023 in fact uh it will
be a charge that pensioners who are
still in work uh will have to pay now
that is designed to address some of the
criticism that you heard uh over the
weekend that those uh who are of working
age are having to pay uh but perhaps
pensioners are the ones
that benefit uh and in addition to that
there is an additional surprise tax that
we uh perhaps nobody anticipated when we
got up this morning and that is a tax on
dividends so people with shares that
sell them uh and then that dividend tax
will go up uh that will also go up one
point two five percent it'll
end up with a tax of around 33 i think
on dividends uh so that will be largely
paid by business uh although some
wealthy individuals also trade in shares
so uh that will be another uh hit to
high earners again addressing those
criticism that we're hearing over the
weekend from conservatives
about fairness and at this point it's
probably worth pointing out nick that it
looks as if the prime minister uh has
pulled off a very interesting trick here
because uh when the reports emerged as
they did just before the summer that
they were looking at uh imposing an
additional charge on national insurance
of one percent maybe as much as uh two
percent at one point uh there was a
human cry for many many tory mps not
just about the principle of breaking a
manifesto pledge which this tax rise
would do 2019 manifesto committed to not
rise national insurance but also there
were concerns about who was paying and
who was benefiting and the mismatch of
that
unnerved many tory mps particularly over
the weekend with several uh speaking out
now it has to be said uh nick that
listening to the commons debate that
took place after uh the prime minister's
uh statement listen to those exchanges
um the level of criticism that you might
have expected having read the sunday
papers was comparatively much more muted
uh there were some small lines
of dissent but nothing bombastic there
weren't there haven't been just to point
it out this is obvious on one level but
there haven't been cabinet minister
resignations ministerial resignations or
great big speeches from significant
backbenchers decrying uh today's new
system which you might have thought
could be happening uh if you uh if you'd
followed the issue over the last few
days about as punchy as it got in the
commons chamber uh was uh the tory
right-wing conservative marcus fish he
talked about uh whether or not the prime
minister would work with him in order to
make the system that he announced uh
less burdensome uh so that's not exactly
on the scale uh of a vitriolic
denunciation but uh given that that's
the kind of tenor of the interventions
from tory mps you can see why boris
johnson and the chief whip
uh are looking to pull off another coup
which is having a made this announcement
today they are seeking to ram it through
the house of commons get an authorizing
vote tomorrow uh jacob rees-mogg has
announced earlier today that this issue
will be addressed on the floor of the
house of commons uh and put to a vote
then so that mps get there a chance to
authorize it for his boris johnson uh
who will outline why he thinks everyone
should back it good afternoon i'm joined
by the chancellor the exchequer and the
secretary of state for health and social
care because today
we're setting out our plan to help our
nhs recover from the pandemic and build
back better by fixing the problems in
health and social care that governments
have avoided for decades
we all know someone whose test scan or
hip replacement was delayed
or who helped protect the nhs amid the
immense pressures of covid by putting
off treatment for a new medical
condition
and now as people come forward again
we need to pay for those missed
operations and treatments
we need to pay good wages for the 50 000
extra nurses we're recruiting and we
need to go beyond the record funding
we've already provided to the nhs that
means going further than the 48
hospitals and 50 million more gp
appointments
so today
following the most successful vaccine
program in the world we're beginning the
biggest catch-up program
in the history
of the nhs
increasing hospital capacity by 110
percent and enabling 9 million more
appointments scans and operations and i
have to level with people waiting lists
will get worse before they get better
but compared with before covid by
2024-2025
our plan will allow the nhs to aim to
treat 30 percent more patients who need
elective care like knee replacements or
cancer screening
a recovery on this scale
cannot be delivered by cheese pairing
budgets elsewhere
and it would be irresponsible to cover a
permanent increase in health and social
care spending with higher day-to-day
borrowing
for more than 70 years
we've lived by the principle that
everyone pays through through our taxes
for the nhs
so it's there for all of us when we need
it
in that spirit from april we will have a
new uk wide 1.25
health and social care levy on earned
income
with the money required by law to go
directly to health and social care
across the whole of our united kingdom
and with dividend rates increasing by
the same amount
this will raise almost 36 billion pounds
over the next three years
not just funding more care but better
care including better screening
equipment to diagnose cancer earlier and
digital technologies allowing doctors to
monitor patients in their homes
the levy will share the cost
as fairly as possible between people and
businesses because we all benefit from a
well-supported nhs and all businesses
benefit from a healthy workforce
and those who earn more will pay more
including those who continue to work
after the stay over the state pension
age the highest earning 14 percent of
the population will pay around half of
the revenue raised no one
earning less than
9568 pounds will pay a penny
and most small businesses will be
protected with 40
paying nothing extra at all
and this new investment will go
alongside vital reform
because we learned from the pandemic
that we can't fix the nhs
unless we also fix
social care
when kovid struck
there were 30 000 hospital beds in
england
occupied by people who would have been
better cared for elsewhere
and the inevitable consequence was that
patients couldn't get the hip operations
or cancer treatment or whatever other
help they needed
and those people were often in hospital
because they feared the costs
of care in a residential home
if you suffer from cancer or heart
disease
the nhs will cover the costs
of your treatment in full
but if you develop alzheimer's or
parkinson's
then you have to pay for everything
above a very low threshold
today
one in seven of us can expect to face
care costs exceeding a hundred thousand
pounds in our later years
and millions millions more
live in fear that they could be among
the one in seven
suppose you have a house worth two
hundred fifty thousand pounds and you're
in a care home for eight years
then once you've paid your bills
you could be left with just 14 000
pounds after a lifetime of work and
effort and saving
having sacrificed everything else
everything that you would otherwise have
passed on to your children
simply
to avoid the indignity
of suffering
so we're doing something that frankly
should have been done
a long time ago
and share the risk of these catastrophic
care costs
so that everyone is relieved of that
fear of financial ruin
we're setting a limit to what people
will ever have to pay regardless of
assets or income
in england from october 2023
no one starting care will pay more than
86 000 pounds over their lifetime
no one with assets of less than twenty
thousand pounds will have to pay
anything at all
and anyone with assets of between twenty
thousand pounds and a hundred thousand
pounds will be eligible for means-tested
support
and will also address the fear that many
have
about how their parents or grandparents
will be looked after
will invest in the quality of care and
in carers themselves
with 500 million pounds going to
hundreds of thousands of new training
places
mental health support for carers and
improved recruitment
making sure that caring is a properly
respected profession in its own right
and will integrate health and social
care in england so that all elderly and
disabled people are looked after with
the dignity they deserve
no conservative government wants to
raise taxes
but nor could we in good conscience meet
the cost of this plan
simply by borrowing the money
and imposing the burden on future
generations so i'll be absolutely frank
with you this new levy will break our
manifesto commitment
but a global pandemic wasn't in
our manifesto either
and everyone knows in their bones
that after everything we've spent to
protect people
through that crisis
we cannot now shirk the challenge of
putting the nhs back on its feet
which requires fixing the problem of
social care and investing the money
needed
so we will do what is right
and reasonable and fair
we'll make up the covid backlogs will
fund more nurses
and i hope we will remove the anxiety of
millions of families up and down the
land
by taking forward reforms that have been
delayed for far too long
thank you very much i'm going to hand
over to rishi rishi thank you prime
minister good afternoon
i'd like to address straight away the
following question
why do we need to raise taxes
three reasons
first we need to properly fund the nhs
as we recover from the pandemic
senior nhs leaders have made clear that
without more funding
we will not properly be able to address
this significant backlog in people's
cancelled operations delayed treatments
or missed diagnoses
to get everyone the care they need is
going to take time
and it is going to take
money the second reason
is that the social care plans announced
today have created an expanded safety
net
instead of individuals having to bear
the financial risks of catastrophic care
costs themselves
we as a country
are deciding to share more of that risk
collectively
this is a permanent new role for the
government
and as such we need a permanent new way
to fund it
the only alternative would be to borrow
more indefinitely
but that would be irresponsible at a
time when our national debt is already
the highest it has been in peacetime
and it would be dishonest
borrowing more today just means higher
taxes tomorrow
the third reason we need to raise taxes
is to fund the government's vision
for the future of health and social care
properly funded
we can tackle not just the nhs backlog
and expand the social care safety net
we can afford the nurses pay rise invest
in the newest most modern equipment
prepare for the next pandemic
and provide one of the largest
investments ever to upskill social care
workers
in other words
we can build the modern
more efficient health and social care
services the british public deserves
to fund this vital spending we will
introduce a new uk-wide health and
social care levy
from next april we will ask businesses
employees and the self-employed to pay
an extra 1.25 percent on earnings
all the money we raise will be legally
ring fenced
which means every pound from the levy
will go directly to health and social
care
the levy is the best way to raise the
funds we need
it is fair
the more you earn the more you pay
it is honest
it is not a stealth tax or borrowed
the levy will be there in black and
white on people's payslips
and it is uk wide so people in england
scotland and wales and northern ireland
will all pay the same amount
to make sure everyone pays their fair
share we will also increase dividend tax
rates by the same amount
and from 2023 people over the age of 66
will be asked to pay the levy on their
earnings too
no government wants to have to raise
taxes
but these are extraordinary times and we
face extraordinary
circumstances for more than 70 years it
has been an article of faith in this
country that our national health service
should be free at the point of use
funded by general taxation
if we are serious about defending this
principle in a post-covered world
we have to be honest with ourselves
about the cost that brings
and be prepared to take the difficult
and responsible decisions to meet them
thank you i'll hand over to the health
secretary
thanks rishi
as the prime minister and chancellor
have just underlined this is such an
important moment for the health and
social care services in our country
over the past 18 months
we've seen how everyone working in
health and social care has moved
mountains
they've treated over half a million
patients with kovid they've jabbed 90
million times
and they've cared for our elderly and
the most vulnerable at a difficult time
inevitably
this has taken its toll
and it's right that we urgently address
it
even when that involves taking some
difficult decisions
yesterday we announced a further 5.4
billion pounds to support the nhs over
the next six months
but we're all clear
this is also the moment to invest in
health and social care for the long term
it's easy to get lost in some of these
big numbers
so i want to set out why this investment
is needed
and where it is going
first the nhs
over the weekend i met health ministers
from the world's biggest 20 economies
we're all in the same boat
left with the consequences of a
destructive global pandemic
here at home before the pandemic
nine in ten people were treated within
24 weeks
now
it's 45 weeks
today
we have a backlog of 5.5 million people
and the potential for that to rise even
higher
i think we can all understand
why this has happened
but none of us on this podium are
prepared to stand by
and watch that figure go as high as 13
million which is what would happen if it
was business as usual
that would be inexcusable
and the responsible thing to do is to
act now
the majority of funds from the new levy
will initially go into the health
service
together
we're investing in the biggest catch-up
plan the nhs has ever seen
and carrying out nine million more
checks scans and treatments
for instance we're going to ensure that
the vital work of routine operations
things like hip replacements cataract
surgery
never stops
and we're also investing in the next
generation of scanners screening
equipment so that we can find deadly
diseases like cancer much more quickly
all of this builds on the historic
levels of funding that we've already
provided since the 2018 settlement
we've increased the health budget year
on year to record levels
because we've all taken our
responsibilities to the nhs very
seriously
and as the prime minister just set out
this is also the moment for another
historic settlement
the moment to stop the crisis in social
care and end the lottery of how we all
pay for it
around one in seven people
end up spending over a hundred thousand
pounds on their social care
and often the heaviest burden falls on
those that are least able to bury it
that's not right
it's not fair and we're going to put an
end to it
from october 2023
no one will have to pay more than 86 000
pounds in care costs over their lifetime
and that cap will be there for everyone
regardless of any conditions you have
where you live how old you are or how
much you earn
we're also casting the safety net
further
no one with assets
less than twenty thousand pounds will
have to make any contribution from their
savings or housing wealth and that's up
from fourteen thousand two hundred and
fifty pounds today
anyone with assets between twenty
thousand pounds and a hundred thousand
pounds will be eligible for some mean
tested support
we know charging reform alone is not
going to be enough so the wider work of
reform also begins now this includes
investing more than half a billion
pounds in the incredible social care
workforce ensuring that unpaid carers
get more support and advice and respect
that they need
and we're publishing an integration
white paper that will help us deliver
health and care as one
so we're making these historic
investments in health and social care
together
they've shown how serious we are about
tackling the challenges that we face the
backlog the social care crisis and we're
not going to leave these challenges to
future governments or future generations
we're making these investments together
so that many millions more get their
chance to live happier and healthier
lives
thank you
thank you thank you very much serge and
uh thank you rishi let's let's go to uh
the the media and can i can i possibly
ask rather asking each of us uh uh one
question could you should you possibly
try and target your questions one of us
and we'll
try and get through uh as many as we uh
as we can or to target one question at
whomsoever you uh you choose laura
koonsberg uh uh bbc
thank you very much prime minister i
think be a shame with the three of you
here if we're not actually able to hear
from all of you but um we'll we'll see
how we get on um
probably going to be a fake faint
request
to you a small proportion of this huge
amount of money will come from dividend
tax but what is fair about a huge tax
rise prime minister that will
overwhelmingly be borne by working
people while the expensive properties of
wealthy pensioners are protected
um to the health secretary but you can
answer this yourself if you would like
getting 5 billion out of 36 billion in
the next three years is going to social
care but what guarantee can you give
people that money will actually go to
social care and that over time social
care will get more of this new levy and
if you can't give us a concrete
guarantee then how are people to believe
that the reform to social care is real
and to the chancellor taxation is going
to hit its highest ever share of
national income according to the ifs
this afternoon can you tell the public
with a straight face that the tories are
still the party of low taxation
uh thanks for very much i knew that was
going to be a vain a vein request but
never mind uh you're quite you're quite
right you're quite it's a very very look
it's a very important subject and
uh you're right to want a range of uh of
questions the the on on the fairness uh
if you don't forget what is what is
happening here we're
in the uh
measures that we're setting out today
we're protecting uh everybody's assets
of up to a hundred thousand pounds and
if you remember the beforehand that was
uh down uh 23 000 pounds that's more
than uh four times as much protection so
people uh up and down the country uh
wherever they are we have assets up to a
hundred thousand pounds uh we'll find uh
that there they get uh they get help uh
we're lifting the the threshold the the
the minimum that uh you uh have to have
before you can be uh asked to pay
lifting that up uh to uh to 20 000
pounds from 14 000 pounds so that's a a
very progressive measure and uh the
institute for fiscal studies have
themselves said today that this is a
progressive and broad-based uh measure
and those it's quite right that those
with the the broader shoulders should
bear the biggest burden and that's
exactly what we're doing because uh the
the the
14 percent of the uh the wealthiest 14
of the population uh will pay uh at
least half of the uh of this uh of this
burden uh of this of this tax yield and
um i i just say to to those who uh who
who say uh you know we shouldn't be
raising uh taxes now i think everybody
knows the extent of uh this government's
commitment uh of the of the financial
commitment that the government has made
to the country during the pandemic 407
billion pounds to provide jobs uh to
support jobs and livelihoods through all
manner of schemes it's it's been hugely
uh expensive but it's been the right
thing to do but it's also now the right
thing to do to take uh reasonable fair
responsible steps uh to put the nhs back
on its feet and and that's what we're
doing
they have wages and people who have
wages and no assets are the ones who
will pay here but everybody uh
laura everybody has relatives uh who can
potentially face uh the costs of care uh
who need better service uh in
the care sector everybody every family
in this country faces this risk and
everybody uh has the uh needs our
wonderful nhs and everybody has as i
said at the beginning has an aunt or a
friend who's
we all know somebody whose treatment has
been delayed as a result of uh of the
pandemic everybody uh needs uh those
waiting lists cleared and that is what
this is uh this is about but uh rishi in
search
thanks prime minister laura i i start by
saying echo what i said in my remarks
none of us standing here wants to be in
a situation where we have to raise taxes
but i think the health secretary saj set
out a a powerful rationale for why extra
investment is needed which i think
people
will understand
and look there is no easy or perfect way
to raise money i'm not going to pretend
that there is we've set out why our
approach this new health and social care
levy is the best way to do it it means
we can do it on a uk-wide basis because
we are a government that believes in the
union and the strength of the union
doing it this way allows us to make sure
that that is a reality it also means
that we do it as the prime minister said
the ifs have called it a broadly
broad-based and progressive way to do it
and it ensures we get a widest possible
participation so as i said look there is
no perfect or easy way to do it but i
think there is a compelling case to do
it and i think we have reasons why we
think this is the best way and even if
people don't like that and i can
certainly sympathize with that and
appreciate that hopefully they will at
least respect the honesty and the
responsibility that we're showing
towards this issue and the way we're
going about tackling it
and laura if i can just add to that if
we had done nothing business as usual as
i called it
the we're being told my officials were
telling the waiting list could rise to
13 million
we were not going to tolerate that and
that's why we took these difficult
decisions to do the right thing i think
what anyone would expect from a
responsible government and to set out
our plans clearly and in terms of the
how that money split it's right that
absolutely most of it in the early years
especially is going to the nhs because
that's where we have the pandemic
emergency and we have to deal with this
backlog and but over time more and more
will start going into social care into
these new plans of the 36 billion 5.4
billion at least
will be going into adult social care and
that will be covering all sorts of
new spending this is additional spending
into adult social care on top of what
the government already provides
including for example supporting 700 000
new places for for training uh work for
workforce your development uh support
and also more money to local authorities
so they can give providers a fairer cost
of care
thanks very much uh anushka astana itv
prime minister the tax rise isn't the
only manifesto promise that you've
broken
today the 86 000 pound cap cannot
guarantee that no one will have to sell
their home and the triple lock on
pensions has been scrapped how can
voters believe what you say and to the
health secretary and to the chancellor
those currently in the care system will
not benefit from this cat that is not
fair is it
thanks very much anushka i just repeat
what i what i said that you know uh of
course you're right but kovid was not in
the uh
uh
the manifesto either and what we're
dealing uh with is is is two things at
once where we're we're using the health
and social care levy which i think is
the right thing to do a legally
hypothecated uh levy uh to to address
the uh the backlogs in the the nhs the
the waiting list so people get the
treatment that they need but we're also
for the first time in in decades doing
something that no government has done
before which is fixing one of the one of
the underlying problems that that causes
those delays in the nhs and that is the
crisis in in social care and people's
anxiety about where their relatives
should best be be treated and uh
the the phenomenon of uh delayed
discharges is is
is partly caused uh by that anxiety and
by the the problems we've got in in
social care so that's why the two things
fit together and why you can't fix the
nhs without also tackling uh the
long-term problems of social care and i
think that that is the right thing to do
and if people look at our at our
manifesto they will also see uh that we
pledge to fix social care after
governments had failed to do it uh for
for decades and we also pledged to be
fiscally responsible
and
not to run up uh excessive uh deficits
uh excessive debts and i think that
people will see that that in the current
circumstances is also the right thing to
do
i can just add to that if i may then
it is the case that these policies on
adult social care they will kick in from
october 2023 and yes it is those that
are the other side of that date it won't
apply to them and that is the case uh
for any new major policy change uh
unfortunately there will be people
sometimes that are the other side of a
start date and i completely understand
the concerns that have been raised by
people uh affected or i guess not
affected in that way but we it's
important that we just get on with this
change it's a big change it's a it's
going to take time to get it right we
need to consult and work with local
authorities and many other stakeholders
in this sector and we'll do that and get
it right and started on time in october
2023.
thanks uh beth ruby sky news um
prime minister you said in the commons
today that you don't break manifesto
commitments lightly you that told that
to your mps but it's not the first time
you've promised
things to voters and then you've broken
them and i'm thinking about no checks
uh on in the irish sea between gb and ni
you promised no cuts to the foreign aid
budget you promised to keep the pension
triple lock you promise no tax rises
breaking promises appears to be past and
parcel of how you conduct business in
your government when you were making
this decision was there not part of you
that worried about it and thought that
at some point voters will lose
faith in you and you will lose
credibility not just for yourself but
for the conservative party as well
and to the chancellor uh you are
traditionally a chancellor who is in
favor of low taxation you're a small
estate conservative as is the health
secretary indeed you're a thatcher i
think
um you've announced today a 10 billion
pound tax rise for workers on top of a
25 billion pound tax rise in the budget
by freezing uh income tax allowances and
thresholds
are you comfortable with the
conservative party losing its reputation
as a party of low taxes and will you
commit today
to actually not raise any more taxes
in this parliament so
perhaps prime minister if you like a
read my lips moment
uh read your lips beth
listen i don't i of course you're uh
you're right about about what you say i
don't nobody lightly uh wants to raise
taxes as as rishi and i and sacher have
all said uh but the the fact is that
nobody uh in any
manifesto that i read uh saw a pandemic
coming in which uh the country had to to
spend
many
billions of pounds 407 billions uh
supporting people up and down uh the
country and putting us in a fiscally a
very difficult uh situation or a putting
a great deal of pressure on our finances
and what we did say uh in that we said
two things uh in that manifesto that i
yeah i have to take a a judgment make a
choice about uh what i think is the
higher priority and i think that what
the people of this country will want
after uh what we've all been through is
uh honesty and fairness and rationality
about the situation and that means
making sure that we don't just leave the
burden to mount up for future
generations
that we do address the costs of the of
the pandemic on the nhs which have been
colossal we need to fix those now but we
also need to fix the one of the
underlying causes of problems in the nhs
social care which has been shirked uh by
governments for uh for decades and which
will help us to fix the problems in the
nhs and also by the way enables us to
fulfill an important manifesto
commitment and enables us to deliver on
the the promise i made on the steps of
downing street and i actually think that
this will make a huge positive
difference to millions of families up
and down the country and i think it's a
a very important moment for for this
country it then you made the promise on
that in the steps of transit how would
you have paid for it
you're using the endemic as cover aren't
you to break tax promises no no no
i think you know most most reasonable
people i can see that as a result of the
expenditure that has been necessary and
the hit that the economy has taken uh
the fiscal position is very different
from anything that could could
reasonably have been uh foreseen uh
before uh the manifesto so you've got
you've you've got to adjust and and take
the do the things that i think are the
priority of the british people and i i
believe that this is our national
priority our i believe our nhs is our
national priority and i don't think you
can fix the nhs without fixing social
care
rishi just add on that beth you know you
asked how will people view us on these
matters which is totally fair i think
first of all people hopefully will
recognize that we do face extraordinary
circumstances and you put some big
numbers on the tax side
but equally people also know we we
borrowed more last year than any time
since world war ii right we're borrowing
more this year than any year since last
year and our debt as a peacetime high so
people recognize we're grappling with
difficult times and you know you said
what will your reputation be well
hopefully you know people will know that
we should have a reputation for being a
party and a government that is
responsible with the nation's finances
and that is really important to all of
us standing here it's a commitment that
we always make to people and they
recognize that sometimes that means you
have to do difficult things and i would
say to people you can trust us to be not
just responsible but take the difficult
decisions when they're necessary in the
best interest of the country and that's
what today's approach is all about prime
minister just fine will you just will
you just rule out any more tax prices so
everyone has to swallow
an ni rise for workers will you actually
just tell the public now that's it
you're not going to spring another
tactic
my admire your your approach uh but of
course uh all fiscal matters of matter
for uh the chancellor is totally wrong
for me so you can ask
rishi too but what i can what i can
certainly tell you is that uh the the
the stand before i can't there are not
uh many people in the in uh in the
conservative party or indeed in you know
in governor or indeed in the
conservative party uh who are more uh
dedicated to cutting
taxes bearing down on taxes where we can
than the three people standing before
you today but i absolutely assure you
the truth of that but we face a reality
which is the the fiscal position has uh
has changed radically from uh the one uh
that we had we found ourselves in in in
2019 and uh we've we've got we can we
can i think the economy is growing
strongly uh we'll come through this very
well uh i i'm very impressed with the uh
the number of jobs that are being
created the growth that we're seeing uh
but uh we've got to be we've got to be
reasonable we've got to be pragmatic and
and and so we're taking the we're taking
the steps that we are um thank you beth
ben riley smith the daily telegraph yes
thank you prime minister one quick
question just to drill down on that
again
uh at heart are you really still a low
tax tory when you think of your own
personal ideology and i will give you a
third chance to rule out this parliament
any further tax rises if you want i
certainly don't want any more tax rises
as part of if you want if you want uh me
to give that uh
emotional uh commitment uh of course
that's the case but it but there's a
there's a there's a formality in these
things which is that uh fiscal matters
are reserved you know these these are
decisions that uh that the chancellor
must make in the course of uh
his budgets and and that's quite proper
and to tory voters can you assure them
you are still a low tax story because
that's what you ran on in 2019. and and
you know i i cut the my share of when i
was mayor of london i cut my
share of the council tax by 20 and i
want to i believe in in
living more money uh where possible to
for people to spend on their families
and their own uh their own priorities of
course that's right but what i what i
just just just
one point i would i i make to you ben uh
thinking uh about uh you know
hard-working families who uh who who try
to do the best for them for them for
themselves and their families this is
something this measure actually uh by
protecting people against catastrophic
costs uh it rewards uh effort uh and
thrift and uh and saving and people
thinking about uh their family and i
think it's actually a profoundly uh
conservative in its and it's increases
it helps people up and down the country
who are working hard for that for their
families i have one for the health
secretary
when this uh reforms come into place can
you promise that no one will have to
sell their home to pay for social care
because that was how this whole reform
was always pitched in the previous years
what these reforms ensure is that people
now for the first time have complete
confidence about the maximum that
they'll have to pay towards their care
so that's the cap the 86 000 pound cap
and no one will have to go beyond that
and that confidence means that they can
plan much better for their future they
can manage their assets better because
as i said earlier that you're one in
seven people at the moment are having to
pay these catastrophic costs of over a
hundred thousand and perhaps because
they had dementia or something else
where they just had annual costs going
on year after year and it wiped out
their total assets so
that can end now because we're providing
this confidence and you're bringing the
the the magic of average to the rescue
of the millions in the in the in the in
the famous phrase the mesa hall for the
express thank you prime minister um
you're breaking your manifesto promises
to pensioners by not raising state
pension in line with earnings aren't you
missing a historic opportunity to
improve what is one of the worst
pensions in in europe state pensions in
europe
having pensioners have a right to build
betrayed and aren't you effectively
robbing them of seven pounds a week
uh
well i hope not mesa and i really don't
think so first of all i congratulate uh
the the express uh for the campaigns
that you run uh on behalf of pensions i
think that they're quite uh right and we
will always stand up for for pensioners
in this government we believe
passionately in that what what we're
trying to deal with is a uh a
statistical freak caused by the kovid
pandemic so that one of the uh data in
the in the trip in the triple lock uh
jagged down and up again uh very sharply
uh with uh a a a weird effect on uh the
on on the on on pensions and uh
pensioners will still get and they'll
still be protect pensioners will still
be protected they'll still get uh two
and a half percent they'll still be uh
protected against rises in the in the
cost of living what we're trying to deal
with is that you know that that big
upward spike in earnings caused which
was a function of the big downward spike
uh caused by caused by cobit and i think
most people can see that i hope and and
i hope that people can see that it's uh
see that it's fair but rishi's only want
to add to that i need to add i think
promises use both statistical anomaly
distortion artificial those are not our
words those are the words of all the
independent commentators about this
issue and it's temporary it's just for
this year and so hopefully pensioners
will feel reassured that not only have
we protect them in the past for
protecting them this year with at least
a two and a half percent increase in
pensions or higher if the cost of living
is increasing faster than that and we
will continue uh with triple lock
thereafter
great thanks uh arj singh from uh from
the eye
hi prime minister another one of your
manifesto commitments was that you'd
seek a cross-party consensus on social
care reform to ensure that it stands the
test of time um why did you fail to do
this and are you concerned that the
social care problem may not be fixed
once and for all as you said as a result
thanks very much argent i i do want to
achieve a cross-party consensus where
where possible but one of the
interesting things that came out in the
in the statement just now in the house
of commons was of course that there was
a cross-party uh agreement by uh the
committee on uh on social care uh that
there should be a uh a levy uh paid for
out of uh out of taxation out of out of
knicks i think in fact they they they
even said and and so there were members
across the the house who backed that
proposal this is uh
identical or very similar to the one
that we're coming forward with today so
i do hope that colleagues across the
house uh will see that what we're doing
is is the right and the progressive
thing uh to do uh that the burden is
being been born overwhelmingly by those
who are most able to to bear it and i
hope that uh that people uh will support
it in the house of commons and uh i i
was i was uh encouraged by what i was
hearing uh this afternoon from
colleagues across the house actually not
just from uh from our benches from other
benches as well
okay folks thank you all very much thank
you
i've had in a long time it'd be great to
ask you about one of the fundamental yes
so let me explain how i have paper i'll
get a here we go i'll go to pippa
okay okay right i could do it you see my
objective in asking for no for not
independently targetable questions was
to try to uh give you all more of a
chance okay we'll go okay we'll we'll go
to pippa and then tom
oh my god that's right well i think i'm
gonna here's what here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna take five more all
right and i'm going to be uh
draconian arbitrary uh uh and ruthless
in the way i decide to to appoint you to
go and go to the pipa first
a little bit more about the care funding
aspect of it which was announced today
the 5.3 billion over three years i mean
some of the care providers are very
anxious about this mencap has said it's
not going to be enough to fix the care
crisis now the uk home care association
says it's nowhere near enough census
described it as being social care system
treated again as the cinderella service
when compared to the nhs is 5.3 billion
plans over three years really enough
given only half of it will be going on
reform how easy will it be at that when
that moment comes to an end to transfer
you like that cash from the nhs backlog
to
um to the social care system and to the
chancellor is there more money likely to
be available in the autumn statement
specif specifically for social care
thanks very much pippa well on on local
councils and social care as as you know
uh we put billions in already through
throughout throughout the pandemic and
uh the the objective of the of the levy
is to ensure that social care gets gets
properly funded but uh
the uh as the as the reforms kick in uh
the increment going to to social care uh
goes up but sag
to that is that this is on top of the
funding system that already exists so
this is your fresh new funding 5.4
billion pounds over the next three years
and in terms of exactly how it's going
to be applied so for example the 500
million pound for for workforce uh
trading we will be consulting with our
colleagues in the sector and working
with them on what's the best way to use
that listing to their ideas equally on
the fair cost of care working with local
authorities across the country to see
how best to use that money great uh
thanks tom young
prime minister one for you or possibly
your chancellor since you've kindly
developed all tax raising questions to
him as far as thought of the treasury
you've hypothecated all this money for
the nhs and social care you'll say
that's going to be legally ring fenced
but what happens come 2025 you haven't
paid down all the money you need to pay
dhs for kovic catch up
will you then keep that 12 billion year
keep on going into the nhs or will it be
then hypothecated for that moment what
was into social care for in other words
will the nhs get the never-ending 12
billion pounds a year extra how do we
know this money actually will go to your
social care plan because that's what we
were uh setting out today and for as
such has just explained uh the the the
reforms and and the improvements in
social care uh
are go go upwards the in expenditure
terms uh over uh the coming years uh but
the priority uh right now is fixing the
electives fixing the backlog paying for
uh the the nurses that we're recruiting
in huge numbers uh doing the
doing the vaccines
but also recognizing that you can't you
can't expect in the long term to fix
these these problems unless you also
deal with uh with social care but anyway
uh uh heather
follow up to that one really which is
what proportion so it's less than one
pound in six of those tax increase that
will be going to social care in the
first three years i wonder what you
expect that proportion to be in say
five years time or ten years time will
it ramp up quite quickly the proportion
that goes to social care will it be when
will it be 50 50. and just prime
minister are you going to reshuffle your
top team this week
all right
[Laughter]
but uh just uh on that that the the
proportions we've set up for the next
three years i think most people
understand the there's a lot of
assumptions we've had to make here in
terms of uh the prevalence of covid the
future directions that will have an
impact both on nhs and uh social care
and then also an assumption around how
much of the sort of missing uh treatment
so so we estimate there's about seven
million people that normally in normal
times would have come forward to the nhs
for treatment they stayed away the
height of the pandemic we all understand
why that happened
but we have to make an assumption around
how much that will bounce back so i
don't want to say you know after three
years it will be exactly this split but
what we do know is that we'll be able to
certainly deal with a huge amount of the
backlog of the next three years and more
of and more proportionately of the
funding through the levy will go towards
adult social care you'll deal with the
whole backlog in the next three years
we're gonna try and tackle as much the
backlog as we can
and we've got to be realistic unless we
do this uh we we can't deal uh with the
backlog in the way that i think the the
british uh public need this is this is
this is fundamental to putting our rnhs
back on its feet uh post covid uh harry
and then jason and then that you didn't
answer her this question about the
reshuffle i know but uh
promises used to admit that national
insurance is a regressive tax that will
hit your constituents harder than it
will hit any well-paid mp as you told
the house of commons in 2002
and a question for the health secretary
if you were still doing the chancellor's
job is this exactly how you would have
fixed the code of black hole
uh harry just quickly uh just just
really to repeat what uh i think i said
to beth earlier earlier on or
this is the ifs to have today come out
and said that this is uh a a measure
that is both progressive and broad-based
it's it's the right way to raise uh the
sums that we need and and to fix the
electives fix the backlog and and deal
with social care i agree 100 with a
chancellor he's been trained well
okay okay okay right jason
uh
yeah thank you um businesses saying that
this is a tax on jobs i mean you guys
used to say this is a tax on jobs do you
accept what business leaders are saying
that this will
uh uh have an impact on jobs and while
we're talking about jobs problems to put
these guys out of their misery is
they're going to be rich
right look first of all what can i just
say uh having having praised the daily
express for campaigning for pensioners i
i do think it's right to say that the
daily mail has run uh a in a historic
campaign to uh on the issue of social
care uh you have you have uh uh had it
on your uh you know it's been part of
your battle cry for uh a long time now
and uh i think it's been the right thing
to call for and uh this government is is
delivering it so i congratulate the
daily mail and its readership for what
they've uh what they've said on uh and
uh on this and i think it's
fundamentally uh right uh and but you
can't do that uh without uh some
uh some ex you know some some tax
raising is in the particularly given the
current context and that's why uh we're
taking the the exceptional measures that
we are and that they're framed uh to
deal with these interlinked problems of
uh pressures on the nhs uh
greatly uh accentuated by delayed uh
discharges
and alleviating that problem of delayed
discharges uh with you know a fund
finally a fundamental attempt to grip uh
the issue of social care so i i hope
that uh uh you know it finds uh you know
i think it's totally totally the right
thing to do and on your point about
the the economy um and you know whether
this will take the air out of the tires
take the wind out of the sails of the of
the of the recovery that that we're
seeing i don't think so uh but i'm uh at
all uh but i i i perhaps i asked richie
to say a bit more about that uh jason so
because of the way that we've done
things in the past the smallest 40 of
businesses so 650 000 businesses won't
be affected by this at all and that's
because of the employment allowance
which we increase in the first budget
that i did the next 40 of businesses so
another 650 000 or so will face an
average increase of about 450 pounds
which for context is about point one
percent of their revenue and less than
one percent of their wage bill and
seventy percent of the contribution from
businesses will come from the largest
one percent of businesses so that's the
impact on businesses which again is
similar to the personal side as i'd say
progressive i think you asked about the
impact on jobs and and supporting jobs
the labour market is performing
incredibly strongly a year over a year
ago we put in place the plan for jobs we
announced that we knew that jobs would
be incredibly important and back then
people were expecting unemployment to
peak at 12 or 14
millions of people unemployed people now
think that unemployment may have already
peaked at less than five percent that's
two million fewer people out of work as
a result of the interventions that we've
put in place we've had now eight months
of more and more people coming into work
six months of the unemployment rate
falling and we are continuing to support
people into work and support businesses
to hire them whether that's through
apprenticeship incentives or if you're a
small company we're giving you 3 000
pounds to take on a new apprentice at
the moment we've created a kickstart
scheme where we're fully funding high
quality jobs for young people with
businesses so across the board you know
i think we are doing an enormous amount
to get people into work and support
companies to hire them and you can see
that in the statistics our plan for jobs
is working okay thank you all very very
much and uh if i've if i've avoided your
uh yours and harry's uh a good question
about uh you know more political more
political matters that is because this
is a a press conference that is that is
focused on that is focused on i think
what matters to the the people of this
country the people of this country which
is building back better from kovid
fixing uh the backlogs in our nhs and
fixing social care at the same time
thank you all very much thank you thank
you
there you go the prime minister turning
there he was joined by the health
secretary and the chancellor for that
news conference lasted about 50 minutes
in its entirety defending the decision
to put up national insurance rates by
one and a quarter percentage points
let's uh join our deputy political
editor sam coats who has uh followed
every word of that summer what did you
make of it no conservative government he
said wants to raise taxes uh boris
johnson he had to do what is right uh
reasonable and fair the chancellor said
borrowing more today means higher taxes
tomorrow so all of them defending this
decision
he set out a very similar case to the
one in the commons saying that it was
unfair of the present that if you got
cancer you didn't have to pay anything
for your treatment but if you ended up
with alzheimer's you did and you could
lose all of your assets we've heard that
continually through the day from the
prime minister let's pick out three
important things from today's press
conference the first was that he refused
to answer beth rigby scones please
collector's question uh or her ask for a
commitment that there would be no more
tax rises in this parliament he just
wouldn't do it he said emotionally i'm a
low tax conservative i can't make that
commitment that is significant second
thing he said that uh he was asked to
defend uh why amongst the vast amounts
of money that are being given away uh
over the next uh three years so it's a
12 billion pounds a year so 36 billion
over three years why only a small amount
of that 5.4 billion is going to social
care and within that quite a lot about
half of that 5.4 billion over three
years is going simply on replacing uh
the funding that people no longer have
to put up when they pay the bills at the
moment themselves the state will step in
he was asked is this enough money to
transform uh social care and that was
the most interesting point of this press
conference was the way that he and sajid
jaffe didn't really engage in too much
detail uh
the the point that actually although
this is billed as a social care
transformation and there are changes the
way people pay it is not necessarily uh
going to
result in a huge injection of fresh cash
into the social care system uh and then
finally he was asked how do we know that
at the end of the three years you are
going to take money away from the nhs
because the backlog's been cleared and
give it to the social care system and
that was where there was a fascinating
admission from santa javid the health
secretary that really all they had to go
on was assumptions they may not have
completed that work so that leaves a
huge question mark over exactly when why
and how much money the social care
system will be getting in three years
time a big admission there from the
health secretary